okay so for people who are watching this
live stream this is a another episode of
our internal design work on supporting
chemistry has a built-in feature of
language and we are about to see some
things that have been done so where do I
start
Jason what should I do here that package
install has been done so okay so to auto
load the package you evaluate just the
word molecule there okay okay let's look
at your screen okay so yeah so it should
work when you run Pacolet installing
this it's something I'll have to work
out to make it wouldn't you just
maximize that window okay okay so so the
basic object is a molecule it has
arguments you can give it the atoms the
bonds a stereo elements come why do we
think that those are I why do we we've
discussed this before this let's see an
example of a molecule here right so this
would be TNT if you were to enter it by
hand you would enter molecule a list of
atoms some atoms have a formal charge
and you need to specify that or else it
doesn't work out and so you can specify
that via property I'm not really keen on
that use of property I mean I think we
did we did we have an alternative to
that from before I didn't I mean this is
this is what I found that to work
otherwise we talked about using
associations here but mom
let's see but just using a list where
you have naked strings and and then
associations didn't seem right so that's
okay I mean that's really okay because
you know the naked string well what what
are the
possibilities here is is it is it mostly
the case that there will be a formal
charge is that the primary modifier that
you'll see rather lots of modifiers that
you might see there are lots so you
could imagine a mass number of a radical
number of radical electrons it turns out
it'll be important to label certain
atoms so that you can refer back to them
okay well okay so first of all that sub
list of the around formal charges
obviously shouldn't be there okay the
sub list there right so if there's just
one property you shouldn't have that
okay but I mean okay I'm not a big fan
of this property wrapper and I mean
these things are basically atoms right
that that's what you that the you know
one could imagine given that you're
using bonds down there we can imagine
some kind of wrapper that I mean I don't
really like the word atom I think we
talked about that before but that would
seem to me to make more sense and you
could have the naked string or you could
have something which just says you know
roughly says atom is that is there
another word for atom that we think we
can use here element but that would be
front with it as my chair that's wrong
right that's not relevant either um so I
also wanted to add an originally but
well it's too it's too close to atom Q
so I'm not sure I'm not sure I mean
I I really think it should feel like
it's designed for this domain and yes
it's a different meaning of atoms and
atoms you but it's safe I think it's
safe in this domain okay at UNK
C and then possibly a list of properties
that it might not right so it's I mean
just type that in for example you know
and you only need that wrapper if you
want to have additional properties right
presumably yes get rid of the braces
right so now and it is possible that
with this atom I'm not really keen on
this
um an absence makes a lot of sense yes
so I like Adam as well yes it's not an
ion is it an ion that it has a formal
charge it's an ion isn't it no right so
so in a molecule if the module itself
had a total charge okay so listen also
the fact that those things are string
look like options but they're strings
doesn't really I mean you know the the
full version of this should be something
I would think where it's an association
inside there where this atom thing is an
association it says atom of association
you know elements arrow n or atomic
symbol or yeah
Tomek symbol makes sense Tomic symbol
makes sense um
Tomic symbol Xen formal charge is one
etc etc and then this other form these
other forms like just atom of N and I
could imagine that we want to support
something where it's atom of a formal
charge is the most common case is it the
most common case yes I would say it's
more common than than mass number a
radical electrons radical electrons mean
unpaired electrons so right so so yes
sometimes you have an unpaired electron
and it makes it a very I you need to
know that in order for to do the
bookkeeping so that you know that it you
all your electrons are accounted for
okay I'm so clueless about this what is
the difference in a formal charge on an
unpaired electron right so a carbonate
so a carbon atom wants to have four
electrons around it if it's bonded to
two four different things it has four
bonds and there are eight electrons in
those bonds but for them are formally
accounted to be on carbon if you take
away the hydrogen atom and both of the
electrons in the bond then you now have
the carbon now only
has three electrons and so it it then
has a formal charge of +1 if you take
away the hydrogen atom and only one of
the electrons in the bond then you have
an unpaired electron there's no charge
on the carbon but it's highly reactive
because it has that unpaired electron
okay but so the names formal charge and
radical electrons are meaning something
very similar but they are very different
names yes I mean so they mean something
related not not identical they have to
do with the the number of electrons
around the atom yeah I understand but
but I
okay let's okay the next thing is even
for example mass number if somebody just
saw this code would somebody immediately
know what that means or would if he said
isotopic mass number or something then
that would be kind of an immediate clue
about what's what the thing actually is
or even just isotope right which you
could just do if you put down there you
know isotope arrow whatever no no and
that answer there you know isotope arrow
whatever you know it will be an you know
nitrogen-14 or something you know
whatever it is that seems to me to make
a lot of sense okay so I mean we could
even call it you know if we want to call
it
instead of Atomics yeah okay go ahead I
mean so so isotope was actually where we
were at in the last meeting and we we
moved to mass number why you thought
that a isotope sounded not as not right
but I'm open to anything I we're putting
given that we're describing this as an
atom okay let's again with this radical
electron thing I don't fully understand
what that means but let's come back to
that let's keep going going down to
these bonds and so on okay okay
according to a standard I you see
classifications okay but this is like
nitrogen 15 what is that 15 in in
nitrogen 15 we say that I mean that is
referred to as the mass number it's the
some of the ideas about taking it to
them it's the sum of the protons and
neutrons I know what it is but I mean
when you say nitrogen 15 what one is
looking for that that the typical sort
of everyday version of that would be you
know uranium-235 you know carbon-14
whatever else right right and it just
seems well whatever okay look we don't
have to solve this right the second I
think they're a bigger fish to fry here
if the top occurs it can be mixed so it
doesn't have to be integer anymore why
it's allowed to present a statistical
mixture in what sense 80 percent carbon
13 and 20 percent carbon-14
sending a mixture of molecules in a
bottle or the probability for a specific
molecule I don't know just all not good
enough to answer this question to be in
the job from the unit tables okay all
right well maybe mass number is it okay
we don't need to go let's go back here
um all right well maybe mass number it
is but but let go back to mass number
that's fine okay now okay but I want to
see okay so these bonds those numbers in
the bonds are referring to the the
indices of the the atoms right so I have
to say I think label and did we talk
about this before why not have in that
first argument if you want to label
something and I think we've done this in
for example and you're on that case why
not have the labels be of the form label
arrow and then the atom gender some what
I'm saying yes so in other words most of
those things would be
just carbon or something that you could
say you know la be well whatever yeah
right it's something like that which
seems much more readable now I don't
know what the difference is so so those
numbers right would be would just be so
this is if you want to index into that
it's a little bit tricky right because
you've got to be able to index into that
thing there and it's like an association
in the sense that than the raw number
gives you yeah I mean yes this is very
much like an association so the raw
number will just index into the location
if those labels have to be strings but I
doubt that we're gonna want those labels
towards be strings I'm making sense so a
possible approach to that would be to
wrap kee around it if it is not going to
be a string okay okay and in the case of
I mean I think you only need the key
wrapped around it in the first in the
occurrence where it's defined in the
molecule I think not sure I have to
think that through a little bit but but
okay
anybody got in comments on this Michael
Roger
no okay so the only uncertain thing I
haven't fully figured out how to do is
to - then how to apply the the labels
after the fact so say you make this
molecule and then you want to apply the
labels to certain atoms well apply them
how so so originally I was thinking that
the label would be in the in the
property wrapper and then I would use
set property oh no please don't do that
how would you do that you'd say set
property of 13 or something to get the
13th Adam yes no we've got to do it by
the label that's on the atom there is no
well they're all labeled or they're not
labeled I don't think there's any choice
there but you might not want them all
there but look look I don't understand
why you're gonna be doing that why not
as opposed to going back into the
original molecule
you're imagining for example some
graphical labeling mechanism is that
right so what I'm so when I do a
molecule plot of it I have these as
tooltips and so that can tell me that
this is atom number two great but then
what would you expect to do to label
them would you expect to go back to the
input form of that molecule so I was so
I'm not sure here I was thinking of
using set property but that's not make a
lot of sense because you're not going to
know I see so your point is if you look
at that picture and by the way I'm not
sure that that is showing molecule like
that is the right thing to do do you
really want to show molecule as it's
just a thumbnail there as opposed to
showing it as a full nice picture of the
molecule so for version one I think at
least this this is good because the
let's see I don't want to just make it
the graphics I would want it to be
something really interactive like like
graph and but but that's but you also
probably want the formula and you might
want the name of the molecule and things
like this so that's as useful as seeing
a picture I would think right when
you're actually working with these
things you want to see the formula or
the name of the molecule mm-hmm right
yes but I think the correct thing to do
would be to have that as some kind of
label on the graphic because I think
seeing you know it's pretty obvious it's
a molecule so seeing the word molecule
there it's kind of amusing but not
really important what does the plus do
shows the smile string at the moment but
no affair
okay there are many more things here
that could go here that molecular mass
yeah it doesn't seem silly at all okay
do other people have I mean that doesn't
seem silly oh the only thing that
doesn't seem right to me is that that
annotation is useful but seeing a bigger
version of the graphic also seems useful
I think what you can do but I you know
depending on your development skills
might be a little bit tougher is
to do an attached cell so if you have a
full picture of a molecule they've tax
cell can have an info box that gives the
equivalent thing of of that plus sign
you know zero saying kind of a summary
of well is that we're not yet doing that
for graphs even are we we're doing it
for images but not yet for graphs we're
doing it for meshes but and we will be
doing it for graphs oh gosh this with
Jason the thing that I don't like with
it is that it only works if to sing it
on its own the attached cell business
yeah I mean I don't understand I think
it's fine to give to do um this stuff
yeah either I'm not I'm not a big fan of
doing that for molecules I I think
that's I think that's interesting and we
could do that but I think it's useful to
be able to see immediately I would think
certain properties of the molecule like
its formula yeah so then I mean all I'm
suggesting is that we make the default
output be something that is plusher than
that little tiny thumbnail and then um
you know we have it is the thumbnail
with some kind of info area underneath
it that shows the formula and that that
is simply our output form for a molecule
and it doesn't have the word molecule in
it making sense by the way by having
atom as a thing inside here and bond for
that matter it's interesting to think
about what the output forms of those
should be I suspect yeah I mean with
bond we could in principle have an
output form that just shows those
numbers and if it's an aromatic bond it
shows it with the appropriate you know
graphical form right yeah let's move on
because we got quite a bit more to cover
here so I wonder I think we're in pretty
good shape here except that I think that
that molecule output display should be
should be Pusha okay let's keep going
yeah so then so there's the bond the
stereo element moment the order so okay
that the autumn is the aromatic etc etc
etc thing right okay
stereo element right so this it's it
takes a second to understand exactly
what these these mean but it's a way of
describing the the spatial arrangement
of atoms right so it is the beyond so
what you've got is the bag of atoms the
the graph of connections between atoms
and the third thing is something that is
going beyond the graph that is some more
geometrical specification that is not at
the level of the actual coordinates of
the molecules of the atoms now where do
we put in the coordinates of the atoms
how do the coordinates get added you can
add them as an option to molecule you
can get a coordinates goes to and then a
quantity array is this what is it
coordinates what would it be in
animgraph
that we vertex coordinates right and yes
so you can't call it coordinates so so
what we're doing right now but I mean I
wasn't it perfectly happy with it but in
chemical data we call them atom
positions for the 3d coordinates and
vertex coordinates for the 2d
coordinates you know that really seems
kind of sucky so I mean why not say I
see so I mean it's a question of atom
coordinates or something as an option
name mm-hmm but but the thing you've
just described those are property names
which are strings yes I'm saying as
afraid now I've got all the properties
of strings but there's no reason that
something as fundamental as atomic not
gonna work what properties do you have a
strings so so a property for a molecule
you can ask say hydrogen's hydrogen's no
no that's a query that's a question
you're asking right that's not something
that is but what do you mean hydrogen's
is false what does that mean so splay
option right no so so internally you can
keep the hydrogen in the chemical graph
or keep them
as implicit you know it's a common
dental molecule it still has the
hydrogen's the question is that's a
display option for whether you whether
you have them I would think that's you
know when you do operations on the
molecule the hydrogen's are there
presumably well oftentimes when you want
to do be a real molecule with its
options included okay so I would say no
don't you have on here
I mean can can you write example so so
this one it's got an input form and so
this one has explicit hydrogen's I I
have hydrogen's as an option for the
creation of them it's not gonna work to
have string options we already went
through this right
how many string options do you have just
a few how many what would are they so
yeah and so these are all strings folks
are this so what do that what is embed
molecule to when you create the molecule
do you want to spend the time in the
effort to generate the 3d coordinates at
the time that you're creating the
molecule and embed them and store them
with the expression or not okay I don't
think that's the right name at all so I
mean I think there's a question of
whether you know what you're gonna have
is something like molecular coordinates
arrow you know there'll be some option
named molecular coordinates and by the
way how you specifying how you
specifying with you giving them in 2d or
3d okay so they can be a quantity array
but they could also be so the question
is whether you want to generate them
automatically whether you want to
generate them immediately or whether you
want to have them be lazy is that right
right
okay so that so my killer coordinates
our or automatic would do something but
it's a question of what what what the
you know which what the different cases
are between doing them okay so I don't
understand if it's lazy how when would
they be generated when you ask for them
when you do a molecule plot 3d okay do
we have a precedent for this Roger can
you think of one yeah I think Charles we
have a bunch of things that are lazy in
fact chose to you have some example
t-mobile is what you mean but well that
it doesn't compute it until you're
trying to plot it it doesn't for example
it would be the example would be a graph
where it does not generate an embedding
until you try to plot it but that's the
case in all graphs right you don't
generate the embedding until you try to
am I not am I correct
yeah that's correct I mean we don't I
mean pretty much for anything we don't
need we don't compute all this when it's
needed right so we just need a name for
you know which might be inherited or all
or something like that for the case or
we might have just a string that says
why don't you write this down as a
string vertical bar and then the string
you know you know something like pre
compute or something right okay yeah he
computed but might be better right okay
so
right and now and then we probably want
something like include hydrogen's as the
name for that that option there and this
Keck utilized thing what is that to do
with benzene or something what is great
it's do you want to do you want to mark
all the atoms the bonds as equivalent
and aromatic or do you want to mark some
of them has double in some of them a
single I see it matters in pattern
matching and stuff in here and the
plotting functions okay so that needs a
name and and I don't think it's that
what standard name in the business for
that operation what does it mean when
you say catalyze it to turn all aromatic
bonds into alternating double and single
bonds is that really what that fellow
did I thought he had his I thought his
big insight was that they were that it
was a superposition of those things
actually no it was that it was a ring
yeah that's what I thought
just that it was a ring just it was a
ring he was the one that no no okay fair
enough
yeah then the notion that there is the
superposition of states is so I don't
understand why it's called Keck Eli's if
if what it really is is - what is the
difference that that you're saying that
you have you either this aromatic thing
or you have explicit alternating single
and double bonds is that right yes
calculus formulas were alternating
single and double bonds and that's why
that name attached to that form okay
fine fine all right well it's a weird
enough word it certainly won't conflict
with anything else and so I calculate I
mean you might say calculus bonds might
be a reasonable name for the origin
Kukui bonds well if it's called catalyze
also so they're oftentimes Cooley
structure
or you take it the structure and you
cool eyes it casual eyes it yeah I don't
like using his name is a verb though
well so okay buy something okay
so let's let's go with that for right
now but so then if I'm not mistaken if
you have so if you've given the
molecular coordinates the stereo piece I
understand what's to waste with why does
stereo element to have a wrapper here
it's the third argument a molecule if
I'm not mistaken right so so then any
structure that you come up with if you
did not give it coordinates needs to
needs to fit that that stereochemistry
relationship I get it I get it I get it
but I mean so that but why is this
stereochemistry for example not given
that molecular coordinates as an option
why is the stereochemistry not also an
option because you don't need you never
need to give both I mean in other words
if you've given the molecular
coordinates the stereochemistry is
completely determined yes
so whether their options are whether
they're a wrapper that's one of the
arguments you will be you would be able
to specify incompatible options and we
need to be that will be something so
something has to win and presumably
molecular coordinates will win but
generate a message yes
saying these molecular coordinates
you've specified are inconsistent with
the stereochemistry I don't really see
that I mean to me it seems that having
the bag of atoms first is it's a little
bit unclear to me I mean the bag of
atoms then the bond structure and then
um you're then after that you are giving
I don't quite see that this why the
stereochemistry should be an argument
there why it isn't an option
well there are cases where people will
draw a structure and they don't specify
the stereochemistry
for example methylcyclohexane or or 1/3
dimethyl cyclohexane what does that okay
so what does the stereo element mean so
what is the one mean that so atom number
one is a is the stereocenter it's a
chiral Center okay and so if and then if
you look along the bond between atom 1
and Adam - Adams 10 9 and 20 will be
arranged in a counterclockwise manner
okay could simply associate this word
counterclockwise with this and the rest
would be inferred but it's not really a
single atom property so we we write it
like this but wait a second but but I
mean isn't that redundant then given the
one do we know from the bond structure
here we immediately conduce just from
the graph theory of it so there will be
four atoms there is that right four
other atoms around this one right that's
the order the order is important I see
but so if you if you don't give this
wise okay but so really it's around one
there are those things and by the way
they're counterclockwise yes okay but we
could assume counterclockwise them it
could be a third argument I think it'd
be more natural to have the the center
first
Roger do we have any precedent for this
in meshes and things no
inorganic chemistry the the four ligands
attached to the central atom are
assigned it can be assigned a priority
and that requires examining the full
molecular graph to do that what we're
trying to do here is something similar
but without assigning the priorities the
priorities would be implicit by their
order and we we could do that Jason and
not have to say that you're looking
specifically from two to one and then
the others are clockwise or
counterclockwise so give it the absolute
stereochemistry rather than the local
stereo we'd still have to be local and
it would be implicit by the the implicit
priorities would be one two three four
or four three two one our choice of the
ligands and then we would just apply you
know the standard RNs rules are for that
in the implicit set of priorities that
does run counter to the true accounting
goal pray log RNs notation though that
would be based on the full molecule so
we need to keep it local we need to find
a notation that works everybody else has
used clockwise and counter clockwise as
the local node labeling for it but the
way they handle what's clockwise and
counterclockwise differs from one
implementation to another okay all right
but but so there's a question of okay
can we I just want to get some scope for
what's going on here I am supposed to
give some video conference talk in six
minutes if it's online and I'm trying to
determine whether it's on time is Eric
here Broderick
okay can somebody find him please okay
well I don't know how long I can keep
going here but but let's get some scope
of what what's happening here
so can you scroll down a bit yeah okay
so that was stereo element also
important is to molecule the way of
ghent generating molecule from a smile
string and in Chi screen string a name
did we have that before previously I
just had molecule taking a string and
evaluating by the way these design
reviews it's kind of important to
remember what it is we already agreed to
what's new because otherwise we're gonna
go back over the stuff we already agreed
to so this is something new is what
you're telling me yes so I was trying to
limit the scope of module and the
evaluation semantics of it
but I don't think two molecule is the
right thing I think that's that's I mean
and this is trying to take the newest
what we have two existing two entity
from entity so sometimes you need to
specify options parsing options options
that aren't necessarily valid on a full
form of an evaluate an evaluated full
form so telling it that that what I'm
giving you as a name and it's not a
Smiles although they I can't even think
of an where they would overlap but
sometimes if you if you give it a
sequence you need to tell it what type
of sequence you've given it okay so hold
on so then okay that's not the main
reason to have other constructors is
when you need to provide control you
know and there's good reasons for
providing that control alright which you
don't think it is the case here that is
that what we're doing
I mean can I just give it a roll
molecule name goes to benzine so that it
I know to parse this as a name possibly
yes but I mean what else would you post
it parse it as I see a smile string or
something right and so so the reason I
wanted this is when you give a smile
string sometimes it's invalid and
sometimes it's invalid and I can tell
you why but if I'm going to just roll
through and try all of these which was
if it were automatic I would just try
this try this try this try this and then
if none of them work spit it back and
evaluate it but if I know that you were
trying it no no but that's just an
implementation detail that's not part of
the design okay um I mean the hey listen
unfortunately I I have to go because I'm
supposed to be going to give this talk
so we have to continue this hopefully
soon like tomorrow ish um before we all
forget what was going on here I mean
this is really cool what I'm seeing here
I just yeah that's some we need to
continue later sorry okay see ya bye